the 2015 Sinquefield cup it's really an
intriguing one because we had come off a
quadrangular tournament in the first one
exactly and then we had a six player in
a second Robin with Fabi winning in
style right
but finally we go back to a classic ten
player format a single game nine run
events right that we all know and love
come to be familiar with and it's a
strong field no question about it
Maurice five of those players five of
the ten were above 2800 IB that's just
so outrageous that's what he's drunk I
mean it was really really an amazing
event but it was also the way the event
behaved there was winners galloping out
of the gate and then falling and other
players coming and in particular you
recall that Magnus Carlsen is white was
playing against Veselin Topalov in round
one and it was a Sicilian and TOEFL op
came out with that g5 move just
electrified us and won the game I
remember a quote reading it in the book
that the same from the signal cook and
he's Gary's saying even my wife knows to
move g5 to get worse off we go g5 had
been a surprise - that was a shocker to
Magnus he's trying to play solid like
what g5 lands on the board and it's epic
to see the world champion lose in round
one you know all the players come in
thinking like a favorite you turn in the
tournament world champion he's the world
champion he's gonna be the one to chase
exact as soon as he loses you get a
feeling like okay all bets are off in
this tournament - has been wounded
exactly and to make it even worse
Veselin Topalov one of the world's great
streaky players like this guy can go on
a roll he goes to an O to start the vet
and then suddenly it was like hey Magnus
regains his farm because I
thing in the next five games Magnus gets
three wins I think for game he at least
out of four he goes three out of four so
he wins the next two draws one and then
wins again to suddenly get up into the
FIR in the mix for first again but in
the meantime Riley very quiet quietly is
Levon Aronian
right Levon you know he likes America it
comes to st. Louis he's feeling good
he's got the Americans and he says
Serena goes okay two Americans two wins
and he's drawing the rest of the field
so he and Magnus are going for the gold
at this moment right they go plus two
Levon as you mentioned beating so and
Fabi right with Magnus shrieking and
then finally T'Pol off gets hit right
and then he gets hit back-to-back it's
five and six and he flames and once that
happens he has no more energy right and
it's clear now that battle is between
Magnus and number-one player in the
world
and Aronian who used to be number two
where everybody used to say was the the
next pretender to use right darling yeah
but granik's his rating goes down after
Fabi rises right with the spectacular
straight year before yeah
and LaVon has a lot to prove it's his
chess game is not looking that great
right so LaVon at one time the dominant
number two player of the world is
suddenly below 2800 he wasn't one of the
five 2800 it's coming into the field
that I mentioned wasn't he 2030 yeah I
thought he was even 2015 he had a big
real real fall from grace okay so there
you go and it's the other thing is it's
like the tournament's really competitive
guys are just winning and losing except
for one guy one guy a nice Gary man he
comes into the event he wins his first
round isn't it sweet he draws the rest
of his games so a guy that we thought oh
he could really be a factor because he
was always on the positive side of the
cross table really never got going after
the first round young as well I think it
was only
at the time the baby grandmaster day of
the group but the critical round was
round seven right Magnus and LaVon are
tied
yep there are plus two great Magnus is
playing against Chris sugar
LaVon with white and it says white
against the Russian Andes and LaVon is
playing Nakamura right and this is the
big round because this dictated what
happened in the Torah indeed
so what happens is somehow Grisham is
playing one of the fabulous games that
Grichuk is capable of playing I mean in
any single moment any of these guys can
beat one another the Grisha for me has
always been one of those players that's
extra dangerous and the weird part again
about Sasha's game is he's constantly in
time trouble and when your opponent's in
time trouble he's nervous but so are you
he's just making every [ __ ] you know
that much more unhappy and nervous and
anxiety risen ridden and that game was a
great game I am Telling You Sasha played
really really well put on a lot of
pressure Magnus was holding holding
holding and when just when he thought he
was going to make a draw then it all
fell apart he loses Levon beats his
third American customer in a row at this
point their fortunes change LaVon is
able to draw his way out of the event
and win and win the third Sinquefield
Cup all by himself he gets remarkable
for Levon as he was trying to prove
something that he belonged yes he knew
that he knew that but he was wounded
right a bit from from not from that fall
from grace exactly I'm not really
performing to what he wants and lavon's
goal has been very clear from the start
he's always talked about it that he
wants to be world champion clear that's
the only thing that matters thread is
trying to become world champion pretty
but he's never done well in two
candidates always done badly and he
managed to win other events as well
right
but this was special to be able to now
win the Sinquefield cup the jewel now on
the tournament circuit right ahead of
Magnus Carlsen right felt like a little
bit of a statement he didn't back it up
in the future years but it felt like a
bit of a statement for him no question
about it
and for us who watched the his victory
his parade to the podium it all looked
so normal like this is my usual routine
this is how I win tournaments just stand
aside and watch how I play and he really
reminded as all of what a great player
he really is Levon Aronian the other
thing about the single cup for 2015
that's super special is it's the jacket
I'm wearing it's the grand Chester that
was the birth of the grand chest [ __ ]
and the sink fell Cup being a classical
event on our very first grand Chester I
just that makes it very special a big
point because it was the year where the
altar box Norway and the sink fill Cup
and the London Chest Classic were the
only events right the grand chest tour
when you look back now and you see the
explosion that has happened yeah now you
have all these events now it's gone to
different continents it's going to
Abidjan in African Cote d'Ivoire in
Africa it's gone it's going to go to
Calcutta India in India suddenly that
time seems so quaint
only three events and yet it's not that
for many years ago it's like when you
hear that expression we've come a long
way baby that's really really really
what it feels like that was very special
the first the first Grantchester event
and the Sinquefield cup you know year -
it felt like it belonged year three it
was zipped into the calendar that was it
the single Cup it's now one of the great
elite tournaments of the world